[Musique]
vous je sais pas mais moi il ya une
expression qu'on entend on a
l'impression que quand nos politiques
nos journalistes posent cette expression
tout est dit et pouvait être réglée
c'est l'expression vivre avec moi je
crois que vivre avec c'est plus
suffisant aujourd'hui d'abord c'est une
contrainte
on vit avec des voisins au dessus qui
font du bruit on vit avec un entourage
qui qui est celui qu'on a autour de soi
et on peut rien y faire
moi je crois à la force du fer avec je
crois qu'on est à une période où une fin
de cycle et les fins de cycle se termine
généralement pas bien qu'elle soit des
fansites climatique qu'elle soit des 26
clubs politiques généralement ça se
termine par une révolution
et cette révolution généralement voit
disparaître une partie de la population
je pense qu'on a la chance aujourd'hui
de vivre une révolution solidaire une
révolution où on peut faire ensemble les
uns avec les autres et surtout faire les
uns pour les autres
quand il ya trois ans avec alexandre
jardin on a décidé de créer bleu-blanc
zèbres on est parti d'un constat qui
nous heurte et quotidiennement qui était
qu'on vivait dans une société qui nous
opposer les uns aux autres ou c'est
tellement facile et tellement agréable
j'allais dire que presse par masochisme
pour certains ou par sadisme plutôt
dortée les populations les unes contre
les autres
d'un côté on va mettre le monde
économique et leur côté de monde
associatif
d'un côté on va opposer le monde du
politique au monde de la société civile
ma je crois que cette révolution
solidaire elle est possible si on
réussit à transformer quelque chose qui
s'appelle la confiance on vit dans une
société aujourd'hui où on nous a imposé
quelque chose qui s'appelle le principe
de précaution transposer le principe de
précaution dans une vie de couple
en règle générale ça se termine pas très
bien parce que je vous demande c'est
d'imposer ce principe de précaution dans
vos quotidiens pourraient revenir sur
une autre image
quand on parle justement dû faire avec
vivre avec finalement ça peut se résumer
à un mille feuilles
c'est joli quand on regarde
mais ce sont des couches qui sont
séparées les unes des autres
le millefeuille vous pouvez le
décomposer vous pouvez le démonter alors
effectivement au goût de temps en temps
c'est bon mais ça reste des strates qui
sont empilées les unes sur les autres et
qui ne se mélangent jamais moi je crois
à l'effet de la mayonnaise
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué à
fabriquer sa peu de la rater mais en
revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on va mélanger ensemble un certain
nombre d'ingrédients et quand on les
mélangera ensemble non seulement ça va
apporter du goût mais en plus ça va être
un révélateur
d'autres goûts dans certains cas et
c'est tout ce qu'on essaye de faire avec
le blazer bleu blanc êtes finalement
c'est quoi
c'est un mouvement citoyen qui regroupe
ce qu'on appelle des faisons c'est à
dire des gens qui concrètement règle un
problème de la société française et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que depuis trois
ans on sillonne le territoire et vous en
avez déjà vu aujourd'hui un certain
nombre est bien la quasi-totalité des
problèmes de la société française sont
réglés aujourd'hui mais simplement ils
sont répartis et individualisé sur les
territoires les faisons ce sont
aujourd'hui près de 300 actions qui sont
regroupés sur la plateforme qui règle
concrètement des problèmes qu'on a
regroupé dans ce qu'on appelle nous des
bouquets de solutions qui sont
concrètement des parcours de vie qu'on
peut rencontrer
emploi logement santé éducation
fraternité tous ces mots m18x de la
société aujourd'hui on trouvait des
acteurs des gens comme vous et moi qui
un jour se sont dit mais je peux agir et
je peux faire bouger les choses on n'est
pas dans un monde de bisounours c'est à
dire que je ne crois pas absolument
qu'on est tous là vocation à devenir
l'abbé pierre
mère teresa ou haute mais je crois qu'on
peut réussir à s'engager à faire
ensemble des choses et quand on a créé
la plateforme ce qu'on a voulu
est ce que l'on veut faire c'est qu'on a
donné aux gens la possibilité de
s'engager une minute une heure ou un
jour qui pas beaucoup une minute c'est
faire quoi par exemple une minute c'est
d'aller simplement faire un tweet ou
faire un live sur une page facebook de
quelque chose que vous voyez et qui vous
paraît important aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux nous donne cette puissance
d'être des petits médias à nous tout
seul donc faire connaître quelque chose
c'est important
une heure
vous avez à côté de chez vous quelqu'un
de bien dénoncer les gens bien ça
changera dénoncer les gens qui font des
choses positives et bien en une heure on
peut aller raconter ce que fait
quelqu'un qui est en bas de chez vous et
de faire connaître cette personne auprès
de la plate forme et bien ça nous a
permis par exemple de connaître
quelqu'un qui s'appelle paul landowski
qui était installée à strasbourg qui a
monté quelque chose s'appelle les cafés
contact emploi et les cafés contact
emploi
paul il est parti d'un constat simple
parce qu'un jour il est allé au pôle
emploi que la personne qui était en face
de lui lui a dit vous savez nous on
pourra rien pour vous donc on espère que
vous connaissez du monde et donc paul il
a dit je peux pas rester dans cette
situation là donc il est allé faire le
tour
dans un premier temps des entreprises et
il s'est rendu compte qu'ils avaient
beaucoup d'entreprises tpe commerçants
etc qui cherchait du monde mais qui
devant la complexité de l'offre de pôle
emploi n'arrivais même plus à aller
déposer une offre
l'autre jour je discute avec une
boulangère qui a déposé une offre elle a
reçu un listing de 2000 personnes pour
un poste de vendeur comment quelqu'un
qui bosse pendant des heures et des
heures chaque jour et le temps de les
analyser un listing de 2000 personnes
donc pas lui ce qu'il a fait c'est que
il prend un cafetier ai dit vous me
prêtez votre café entre 10 heures et
midi
tous les gens qui viendront consommeront
et moi ce que je fais c'est que je fais
venir du monde dans votre café donc il
va voir les entreprises sur la zone de
chalandise les tpe les commerces et de
l'autre côté il fait venir du monde
chaque entreprise à 3 minutes trois et
cinq minutes pour présenter son activité
et en face il fait venir des candidats
potentiels demain paul organise à
avignon son 183e café de l'emploi chaque
café ça dure deux heures dix pour cent
des gens repartent avec un contrat de
travail
coût pour la société zéro donc ces
personnes là on l'a identifié je reviens
à mon point de l'identifier quelqu'un en
une heure parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
un jour a dénoncé paul en disant ce type
est un type extraordinaire et puis un
jour eh bien c'est que vous pouvez vous
aussi devenir véritablement des acteurs
dans votre quotidien
un jour c'est vous décidé d'organiser
par exemple un café de zèbres en bas de
chez vous donc c'est réunir des gens qui
dans votre immeuble dans votre rue
partagent à peu près les mêmes envies
les mêmes besoins que vous ayez envie de
faire mouche
les choses moi je fais de la politique
je fais du politique vous verrez jamais
les zèbres demain devenir réel et
revendiquer un poste de maire d'adjoints
au maire ou quoi que ce soit c'est pas
ça l'enjeu il n'est pas là l'enjeu il
est véritablement de nous donner à tous
les moyens d'agir de devenir les acteurs
de notre quotidien de devenir des vrais
faisons parce qu'on est tous à
fondamentalement au fond de nous mais
simplement on n'ose pas je reviens sur
l'expression dû vivre avec ma pendant
très longtemps je me suis contenté que
ça en me disant ben voilà c'est bien je
vis avec jeudi à la porte aux gens etc
et bien non on peut aller plus loin que
ça on peut réussir à véritablement
structuré des offres structurées des
messages qui font que on peut faire
bouger réellement les lignes pour
terminer j'aimerais revenir sur quelque
chose qui pour moi est quelque chose
d'assez essentiel on vit dans une
société qui est un peu merveilleuse
quand même malgré tout on peut toujours
la critique et on peut toujours
considérer que les choses vont mal on
vit pas dans une période euphorique pour
autant
mais ce que j'aurai s'est rappelé les
trois mots qui sont posées sur les
frontons de nos mairies entre autres
liberté égalité et fraternité
les deux premiers dépendent de l'état
quand on compare la france d'autres pays
la france est un pays où dans lequel on
est plutôt protégé en termes de liberté
et d'égalité
le troisième point qui est la fraternité
ça revient ça repose sur chacun chacune
de nos épaules
c'est à nous d'être les acteurs de cette
fraternité là donc pour revenir à ce que
je disais au début faire avec s'est
reposé sur cette notion de piles un
veillance c'est un mot qui a disparu
quand j'entends les débats actuels
quand on voit la façon dont on essaye de
nous réduire le discours politique au
travers de recherche de petites phrases
sur bfm sur i télé ou autres types de
médias on ne peut plus réduire notre
monde à ça et en tout cas nous sommes
tous responsables si nous nous laissons
enfermés là dedans donc ce que je vous
propose comme simple petite chose à
faire c'est aller sur la plateforme de
blanc même si vous avez envie dénoncé
des bonnes pratiques
si vous connaissez des gens qui ont
envie de faire des choses ou qui déjà
font des choses
je vous donne mon portable on a toujours
fonctionné comme ça parce que on part du
principe que les gens l'utilisent à bon
escient et avec alexandre on a construit
l'ensemble des marches comme ça 06 20 71
94 20 et on était votre disposition pour
que vous aussi vous puissiez vous
embarquer dans cette formidable
révolution qui la révolution de la
solidarité
merci
[Applaudissements]